in this video of us Emily Step 1 high
yield series we will talk about Julian
Barre syndrome it is an acute rapidly
progressing demyelinating autoimmune
disorder of peripheral nerves
it is also known as acute inflammatory
demyelinating polyneuropathy in short
aidp the risk factors include preceding
infections of campylobacter jejuni
several viral infections and in rare
cases influenza vaccination
the clinical presentations include for
motor system there is an ascending
paralysis
which is symmetric and progressing over
days the pattern is distal to proximal
usually known as the stocking and glove
pattern
in severe cases this paralysis can
Ascend further and can involve the
muscles of respiration and diaphragm in
that case it can lead to severe
respiratory
problems and can also lead to death
sensory system involvement is presented
by stocking and glove pattern of
paresthesia there is also autonomic
dysregulation and an reflexia
visible symptoms include numbness in
hands and legs which correspond to the
motor anomaly tingling sensation in
hands and feet which correspond to the
sensory modality there is swallowing
difficulty and shortness of breath when
the disease becomes severe and involves
the muscles of respiration and
deglutination
hypnosis involves nerve conduction
velocity study which is known as ncv
there is a decreased ncv that is nerve
conduction velocity indicating a diffuse
demyelination myelination increases the
nerve conduction velocity but over here
demyelination reduces the velocity
also you can do a lumbar puncture and by
that you can collect CSF in that CSF you
will see increasing the level of
proteins particularly albumin whereas
There is almost no pleomorphic cells
this phenomenon of increased protein and
decreased on meal cells present is known
as
albuminocytological dissociation
a very important differential diagnosis
emerges at this point which is Tick bone
paralysis
both GB syndrome and tick bone paralysis
are ascending paralysis however in case
of tick bone paralysis there is no
aluminocytological dissociation in CSF
as well as there is absence of autonomic
dysregulation
treatment includes plasmapheresis and
intravenous immunoglobulins as the first
line
corticosteroids are not usually
indicated
frequent monitoring of respiratory
function is essential to determine the
need of ICU admission in case of
impending respiratory failure
aggressive physical rehabilitation is
needed
and the recovery may take up to one year
in summary Guillain-Barre syndrome is
acute inflammatory demyelinating
polyneuropathy that is aidp
it is characterized by ascending
paralysis
there is autonomic involvement and there
is albuminocytological dissociation on
CSF studies these are known as The Four
A's of Guillain-Barre syndrome I hope by
now you have got a clear idea of
Guillain-Barre syndrome to get high
quality nodes and flash card you can
follow us on our Facebook and Instagram
page at animated biology with Urban
also we need your support to make free
high quality content for that you can
contribute using the super thanks icon
present on the bottom right corner of
this video you can contribute using
paytm PayPal or UPI also you can go to
our patreon page and support us there
if you wish to connect use the following
links and for medicine related content
you can follow the nerd medic on YouTube
until then bye bye see you in the next
one